okay so I think it's about time we did a
super hard Dragon Ball quiz that isn't
one of those super easy ones that is
pretending to be hard but this was
actually hard okay so let's start off
with question number one and this is the
softball question okay what is the name
of the mountain that Chichi's father Ox
King had his castle atop up the answer
is Mount frypan get it because it was so
hot yeah haha Tori am I very funny okay
question number two what actor played a
role in not only the English dub of
Dragon Ball super but also Dragon Ball
Evolution any guesses
the answer is James Masters he played
zamas of course but also played Piccolo
in evolution question number three the
hardest question mind you what is the
name of the city where Android 17 and 18
from trunks's timeline meet their end
parsley City and you thought Saiyans
were the only ones named after food
Torah to you